this is fun yes Anne Hathaway is
absolutely slaying it on the Dance Floor
I mean I I'm not I'm not embarrassed and
you shouldn't be Dancing Queen Anne is
living it up and having the time of her
life at Paris Fashion Week
[Applause]
the Oscar winning actress attended the
Valentino fashion show rocking a leopard
print mini dress along with matching
tights and heels she even made it a date
night with hubby Adam Shulman
she kept the fun festivities going by
letting loose at the designer's after
party
and Anne's dance moves are so perfect
they've gone viral kind of a big deal
I'm saying I'm trying to stay chill but
I'm very happy about this development
but but get this and he's no stranger to
going viral at Fashion Week how about
that a New York Fashion Week last fall
she's stunned in an outfit eerily
similar to a look she wore in the Devil
Wears Prada
and you have no style or sense of
fashion
well um
I think that depends on what you're you
know
that wasn't a question and told ET the
twinning moment with her character Andy
was purely an accident I wish that I was
this clever wouldn't it if I I wish I
had this kind of I don't know
Machiavelli in tendency and I could like
move all the chess pieces and make you
all feel how I wonder the truth is it's
just it was the outfit that came the fit
and that was the best hairstyle for it
and it turns out people really like the
Devil Wears Prada it was a funny
coincidence on the way out the door I
was like oh I wonder if anybody will
notice
I wonder I think no no really because
because the thing is is like I don't
stop and focus on it but like it was a
beautiful kind of I think if anything it
was just a testament to people's love of
the movie and How Deeply they've taken
that film in and that's just a wonderful
feeling I just feel lucky no Anne we're
the lucky ones thank you for sharing
these iconic moves with us
all right